une superficie de 520 mètres carrés un
parking privé de 26 places pour un coût
total d'un million huit cent mille euros
ce nouveau pôle santé
pluridisciplinaires répond à une
nécessité de la ville de coignières de
s'adapter aux besoins de sa population
précédemment nous avions bien sûr un
centre médical et qui était situé rue
des étangs dans un ancien pavillon et
qui n'étaient plus adaptés aux personnes
notamment à mobilité réduite et qui
n'était plus conforme si vous voulez aux
nouvelles lois concernant le handicap
ce bâtiment beaucoup plus fonctionnel
bâti de plain pied au niveau
rez-de-chaussée accueillis dès son
ouverture les médecins locataires de
l'ancien centre
dans l'état actuel nous sommes deux
médecins généralistes un gynécologue
en tout huit praticiens médicaux
paramédicaux c'est à dire une kiné les
podologues pour l'instant une partie du
bâtiment est encore disponible à la
location pour de nouveaux praticiens
spécialisés qui manque encore dans la
région pour des raisons de démographie
médicale
malgré l'attractivité de ce nouveau pôle
santé il ya de nombreux besoins qui ne
sont pas satisfaits à coignières par
exemple orthophoniste par exemple
étoffer l'équipe qui n'est par exemple
un dentiste qu'il n'y a plus
malheureusement à coignières et puis
d'autres spécialités comme par exemple
ophtalmo dermato pe rhumatologue que
dans laquelle il ya une énorme demande
qui n'est pas satisfaite
ajouté aux anciens patients de la pmi de
coignières désormais fermé de nombreuses
personnes de communes limitrophes se
rendent dans ce pôle santé qui pour
l'instant enregistre déjà une trentaine
de consultation en moyenne par jour